ciao, come se stessi pensando di
fare un video sulle mie reazioni da
seguire e sulla mente del film e mi
dispiace fare questa cosa in inglese ma
penso che finché ci sono molti
più fondi di lingua inglese tra  il
mondo che qui in Italia penso che ci
sarebbe la cosa più importante da fare
quindi voglio solo iniziare dicendo
che non voglio prima di nessuno Oh
vedi ho tutti i libri e sono
cose carine ma qualunque cosa  lo chiami e in
realtà mi considero un buon
evento per i fan anche se diciamo solo che il
film era un po' diverso perché
più mi aspettavo di vedere ok ama
il terrorizzare significa IA non lo
so non ne sono sicuro e tutti noi  vedere
sono le due lacrime della carta principale che
sarebbero giuste se stessero facendo chi fa essere
diverso come il suo strizzare gli occhi
e accigliarsi e muoversi per un mese in un modo
per giocare qualunque cosa ha detto bene d'
altra parte sei appena morto  mi piace
mescolare puro odio e disgusto, quindi punta
alla fine o  r possiamo dire qualcosa la sera
e la cosa divertente è che come dopo
due frasi come se pensi che
tu sia così bravo a scaldare il sangue servi
che non possono essere amici non possiamo essere
amici
scusami non c'è modo o possono essere
amici  ti so anche che succedono
loro Hollander e poi vanno avanti fino
alla fine dove se non sono caro oh
ragazzo sono il cattivo
un fratello Tyler stai lontano da te e
se succede qualcosa
niente può scaldarmi finché io  posso
amarti sei come il mio tipo preferito di
fretta con te ti ho
aspettato così tanto per tutto il tempo mi sento così al sicuro
se mi dicessimo di guardarmi il collo con
occhi così affamati ma potrei ucciderti in  il
boom e così via e poi sai che c'è
solo divertente a cui pensare penso di sapere
chi sei
dopo una breve ricerca su Google
grazie al mio nuovo nuovo lavoro di rimonta
possibilmente veloce e forte la tua pelle risparmia
un bel segno sì i tuoi occhi
cambiare colore e talvolta parlare come
se potessero formare una tim diversa  e non
mangi né bevi mai niente non esci
alla luce del sole quanti anni hai 17
sei stato morso 17 Wow penso di sapere
chi stai dicendo ad alta voce
mio padre ha detto whoa oh per favore non sono come
lui
Homer Simpson
oh no per favore guarda Roger Rabbit
ho avuto gli stessi draghi Faisal
aspetto Sharon Stone guarda ma il collo succhia il
sangue
un vampiro hai paura